Hi, I'm Marti's grandson and today's
next level chips is about how to change the
location of your application installation
knows when the user tries to install the
application and even having a good
an SD card ends up receiving an error
Lack of memory
this happens because the application does not
is configured to allow
installation other than the
phone's internal memory from the
android 2.2 the pelé v8 is possible to place
a parameter in your manifest for
change this location to this parameter
called android 2.1 installed complaint '
where you can specify some
parameters to change your configuration
as a glance at these options the
the equivalent of not placing
no configuration since it is the default
will cause the application to be
installed internal memory only
device and also does not allow you to
on sd card
then there is an external super flex where
you give the option of preference is for
sd card installation and also allows
that the user moves the phone to a
new back psd if you find it
necessary and lastly we have the
where you delegate the decision to
where the application should be installed on
if by default the first attempt is
always the internal memory of the device
and then try in the external memory that
available if available
here we see an example of a
Manifest where I put the option
android 2.1 installed keys as you prefer
external or will first try
to install in cairo st
This is the tip of today.
close